- All right, let's wrap this
hour up with one last story
to delight the senses.
This is What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
Chicago has a new top dog
and the trophy to prove it.
She earned the title by beating
out more than 4,300 people
by visiting 367 Vienna Beef hot dog stands
in the Chicago land area,
and driving about 8,000
miles in just five weeks.
I love this woman.
She's so competitive.
(audience laughing)
That should earn anyone a
trophy, is all I'm saying.
But she didn't just land
herself a cool memento,
she also won a few other prizes
she's sharing with the
kids in her community.
Let's get this top dog on the line.
She watches on NBC Chicago at two.
What's up, Stephanie?
(audience cheering)
- Hi.
How are you?
So, tell us more about this contest
and how you pulled off the win.
- Yeah, so my boyfriend sent me a tweet
that Vienna Beef was having
this hot dog stand challenge.
And I am super competitive in anything
with the word challenge, I am
going to dive right into it.
(audience laughing)
So I had one of my friends help me
and made a Google map,
so I could navigate all around Chicago,
Illinois, Wisconsin as fast as possible.
I'm hyper organized.
I had spreadsheets with me.
I averaged at least 10 stands a day.
I would leave work and then drive an hour
through rush hour traffic
to get to hot dog stands.
One weekend, I drove from Chicago
all the way down to Carbondale and back.
So 1200 miles in one weekend.
I would go into hot dog stands,
and the owners would be super excited
because the person who was in
second place was just there.
When I was in second place,
the person who was in first
place was there just before me.
So it was super fun.
It was exciting to get
out and see the state
and do something new.
- And meet all those people.
That's so cool. What a cool trip.
So what did you win besides the trophy
and bragging rights, of course?
- So other than this amazing trophy,
(Kelly laughs)
top dog and bragging rights,
(audience cheering)
I got some cool swag.
I also got sports tickets for four
for the entire year to all
the different sports arenas
here in Chicago.
- Wow!
- Food and drink
is included with that.
And I also got a $1,000
gift card to Vienna Beef.
I work with kids and seniors
here at the Park District in Chicago,
so all that money is going right back
into the kids and seniors
so we can throw huge parties
all year long for these kids.
And then also, Vienna
Beef wants to make sure
that you are in on the fun too.
So you're gonna get some Chicago hot dogs.
- Look, I can smell it from here,
and I just saw Justin...
Thank you, Justin.
- You're welcome.
- I love my job, Justin.
(audience laughing)
I just feel in honor of you and your win,
I should celebrate with you.
So here we go.
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
- That's good.
Oh my God! I would've
never loaded it like this.
That's really good.
Now I shall.
Thank you so much, Stephanie,
I'm liking your post right now.
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
And that's not all.
Our season-long partner Pilot Pen,
the go-to pen of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
thinks that your mission
and what you're doing
with the winnings is so great.
So in recognition, they'll be using
their FriXion Erasable Pen
to write you a check for $1,000.
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
- What?
Oh my God. That's amazing.
Thank you.
- That's amazing.
- Oh my God!
- Well, thank you so much,
and thank you for this delicious hot dog.